how would you tackle climate change  Jesse no such thing okay  and and elaborate on that it's a made-up  lie about the liberal Democrats in order  to get more money and power and control  the people climate change is fake  you know in some countries uh climate  change is much less politicized in other  words you might have scientists who are  conservative and scientists who are  liberal and they all agree about it why  do you think in other countries even the  conservative scientists accept the  science on climate I have no idea but in  America climate change is fake in them  in America even in those maybe in those  I don't know for sure but maybe in those  other countries they're controlling the  people because the people weak mind it  and they allow themselves to be  controlled by lies interesting